and we were we're gonna be in Leeds
because I'm Sophie morning and with the
city was split pretty much 50/50 when it
came to breakfast as the MP for the area
do you think people are more or less
divided now
well the constituency that I represents
one of the eight constituencies in Leeds
voted heavily to leave but as you say
across the whole of Leeds it was
basically 50/50 and people still hold
strong opinions on this what people want
most of all though is a way out of this
national crisis that the Conservatives
of cause and that's why I think Jeremy's
been right in his recent speech in
Wakefield and his speech earlier this
week in Hastings so talk about bringing
people together who voted leave and who
voted remained because we believe that
the real divide in our society isn't
between those who voted to leave and
those who voted remain but actually
between the many and the privileged few
at the top that been doing very well
because whether you live in Huddersfield
and voted leave or in Hackney and voted
remain he's still facing many of the
same problems problems of low wages
stagnant wages the housing crisis
austerity the cuts to public services so
what we want is an end to the division
in our control to bring people together
run a common-sense traditional British
compromise that can get out of this
impasse that the Prime Minister has
caused you're very clear there that you
are pointing the finger of blame at the
Conservative Party but I just want to
put you a few things that the Labour MP
David Lammy has just said on the show he
says that when it comes to brexit Jeremy
Corbyn is hedging that election is very
unlikely to happen and if Labour doesn't
have more of a solid position on brexit
and he wants to see a second referendum
of course then the party could split is
he right well I don't think the party's
going to split but David does hits up on
an important point which is Jeremy as a
leader of the Labour Party for the whole
of the UK if somebody is wanting to win
the next general election to get a
Labour government that can heal those
divisions and get a government for the
many not the few
plus those policies but also labor not
just in Leeds but across the whole
country
represents both communities that voted
leave and communities that voted remain
that's not a problem the Conservatives
have it's not actually a problem the
Liberal Democrats have either I think
it's a good problem to have and it makes
us uniquely placed to bring people
together
most people don't define themselves
primarily as remain as or leavers when
it comes to their view of politics or
their view of life of course some do and
I respect their opinions we need to
bring people together around the
bread-and-butter issues but we're not
going to be able to do that if we have a
disastrous
No Deal brexit which what the Prime
Minister is threatening us with so our
priority is to stop a disastrous No Deal
briggsie and we think that our proposal
actually offers a way through that which
will bring people together and command
the support of the majority the House of
Commons - well in the spirit of bringing
people together
Therese Mae's been inviting members of
opposition parties into Downing Street
to try and find a way through the
current and gridlock when it comes to
brexit the party leaders went Jeremy
Corbyn didn't go and this is what he
said in May 2017 you've got to work with
people who often you don't agree with
there has to be a process in which
people talk to each other what happened
to the man who believes and talking to
all sides well he and Labour do believe
in talking and negotiation productive
discussions the reason that Jeremy said
what he said in Parliament and he said
he's happy to meet Theresa May to work
out a way through this national crisis
he said let's start off by the Prime
Minister taking a disastrous no deal off
the table that would harm communities
economically in terms of jobs both who
voted leave and who voted remain he said
he wouldn't go so what would be in
effect a PR stunt for the prime minister
at that point all the political parties
at the Lib Dems the green MP and plaid
calmly went to see the prime minister
and were disappointed when they came out
and found out that indeed was the case
that Theresa May wasn't being flexible
she wasn't prepared to take no deal off
the table the Prime Minister's trying to
hold the country to ransom
threatening those who voted leave that
unless we supports her rotten deal will
remain in the European Union and
threatening those people voted remain
but unless we support her disastrous
deal then we're going to crash out of
the European Union with no deal the e
what we don't want is to take part and
this is why Jeremy's already said last
week what we didn't want to do was to
take part in what would really could be
a PR stunt where the Prime Minister was
cynically using all the parties goodwill
in order to run down the clock further
further towards the disastrous No Deal
bread that she's threatening the country
with if she takes it off the table as
she thought as she do as plenty of
people in her cabinet and party wanted
to then I think we can bring the country
together and get a way out of this
national crisis